all my years of making videos and
Hoboken have prepared me for this
there's an airport right there planes
taking off you probably see some
construction down here let's just do it
anyway hey what is up guys I'm Kitty HD
here and I'm on my hotel in Las Vegas
pre CES 2016 and asked you guys on
Twitter if you guys had any questions
about CES or anything else tech related
and you had plenty so let's get into a
pros and cons of switching to final cut
alright so if you guys follow me on
Twitter then you already know that I
recently switched from Adobe Premiere as
my main editor for like the past five
years to Final Cut Pro 10 it's gotten a
bad rap in previous versions but
actually really liked it the main reason
I switched and the biggest Pro is
performance render times playback
smoothness all of that is much better in
Final Cut and Premiere I guess the
biggest thing I'm losing a biggest con
would be all the plugins and all the
effects I use with Premiere but I'm
finding them slowly not tech related but
pancakes or waffles pancakes good I feel
like I've answered that before
hopefully I said pancakes last time
right the most common question what are
you looking forward to the most at CES
2016 and why CES as I've said before is
becoming more of a niche show with less
important devices the more risks and
more fun stuff I feel like this year is
going to be more of like a car show all
the car tech that's been getting better
in the past couple years is going to be
neat to see Android auto apple carplay
all the in-dash stuff getting more
high-tech in cars that's going to be
cool but we're going to see stuff like
the crazy 8k TVs the awesome displays
the virtual reality stuff all the stuff
is going to be at CES just because
that's the nature of the show what have
you brought with you to edit with I
brought the 15 inch retina MacBook Pro
that showed in dope tech number two you
guys saw the all matte black painted
version super high-end that is what I'm
using to edit and like I said it's going
to be running Final Cut do you think
fingerprint sensors on phones are a
necessity no I don't think they're in
necessity they're still pretty cool to
have especially in the highest-end
phones that do it really well that's
going to be something I look forward to
but I don't think there's going to be a
time where every smartphone has to have
a fingerprint sensor but it is pretty
nice though Tesla Model X review you
know what I would love to if anyone at
Tesla is watching this or if anyone has
a contact at Tesla or if any of you guys
have a Model X
want to let me use it for a video I will
gladly make a video about the Tesla
Model X how about what's in my bag video
for CES 2016 alright let me actually
pull up the I put an Instagram photo of
the exact bag that I packed so I'll show
you exactly what's in it I saw the red
weapon dragon at the bottom right with
the 7 inch monitor on top that I'm
recording on right now to the left of
that are the batteries to the left of
that is the microphone the Sennheiser
MKH 416 above the batteries is the
second cos 11 D the lab mic I'm using
right now which is doing a pretty good
job above that is a canon hundred
millimeter macro but that is the Sigma
18 to 35 my go to and then to the right
of that is the canon cine 14 millimeter
lens which i'm using to record this
video up top is the sound devices mix
pre d and some cables some power stuff
and then over to the right is a little
XLR cable and my mini mag reader for
reading the SSDs that this camera uses i
definitely won't be bringing all that to
the show floor though the idea of going
the shows to be as lightweight as
possible so i'll have a backpack with
about half that stuff and i tend to not
do any audio stuff on the show floor
itself so it's just going to be
capturing video have you ever dropped
the weapon or any other expensive gear
god no i've never i mean you're probably
jinxing me now that I'm saying this I've
never dropped anything like that super
expensive last piece of tech that I
dropped was a phone the Moto X the first
Moto X and it didn't even break hold the
new Nexus phones be called this year
Nexus 7 will you buy an 8k TV this year
and if yes were you planning to get 8k
videos from I would guess that no I'm
probably not buying an 8k TV this year I
hope I'm wrong I hope it events is
superfast but the chances of having a
whole bunch of a.k videos to watch that
look way better than the 4k OLED TVs
that are already out it's pretty slim
although again I hope I'm wrong
have you seen even one person wearing an
Apple watch yet yes the person who sat
next to me on my flight was wearing an
Apple watch you get special treatment
when you are going to CES as a youtuber
no in fact it might have been the
opposite like two or three years ago
youtubers got sort of less than standard
treatment I guess now it's a little
better because youtubers are being more
recognized as a part of press but no
it's it's pretty much like the rest of
the press experience now if you had to
compare phones to NBA teams what phone
would you say the Clippers
Lakers and warriors are at the
california team's I would say the
Clippers are probably like a probably
like an LG v10 where they do one thing
really really well jump shooting and the
camera sort of like a specialty the
Warriors are probably like a Nexus 6p
like they don't really have much of a
weakness that you can attack they're
pretty much set and the Lakers are
probably like a like a blackberry proof
all right that's my time guys thank you
for watching this ask me video hope it
was a little different a little bit of
fun sorry if you couldn't hear anything
I was saying crawl construction noises
it's a little worse in hoboken which is
something I thought I would never say
but anyway catch you guys at CES if you
see me there say hi talk to you guys in
the next one peace